[Musica]
Freud teorizza che nel terzo momento
dello sviluppo sessuale di un essere
umano la bambina si accorge della
differenza anatomica tra lei e un
bambino e in quel momento prova un una
terribile sensazione di angoscia quasi
una castrazione un evirazione
Freud la chiama invidia del pene io l'ho
chiamata invidia del pane perché nella
prima parte della mia vita Ho provato
anch'io questa sensazione di mancanza di
incompiuto di un senso incompiuto c'era
qualcosa che non mi faceva sentire
collegata a me stessa io sono Francesca
Ho 38 anni e nella vita faccio il pane e
non avrei mai pensato di trovarmi qui
oggi a raccontarvi questa
storia sono nata a Senigallia in una
piccola città di provincia quindi della
Costa Marchigiana e sono ho cresciuto
sono cresciuta con un'infanzia Felice in
una famiglia che mi amava e che mi ha
sempre curato e due dei primi
protagonisti di questa storia sono
Giorgio e la Clara i miei nonni due
Romagnoli emigrati al sud due persone
che avevano un sacco di valori nella
loro vita uno tra questi era il cibo per
loro uno degli insegnamenti più
importanti era quello di farmi capire
l'importanza del linguaggio del cibo
della lingua del cibo
Infatti uno dei ricordi più Ferri più
sigillati che ho nella memoria sono le
mattine di giugno quando la scuola era
finita e mia madre mi accompagnava dai
nonni perché andava a lavorare e invece
di andare in giardino a giocare con
altri amici mio nonno mi obbligava ad
andare al porto a imparare a comprare il
pesce diceva Francesca tu devi guardare
il pesce fresco lo devi saper
riconoscere devi parlare con il
pescatore che lo ha pescato ugualmente
ci spostavamo nelle campagne
incontravamo la Giuliana che ci dava le
uova incontravamo Mario l'allevatore di
conigli e tutto questo si trasformava
sempre in fantastici piatti e ricette
della Clara che componeva il menù
settimanale ma contemporaneamente però
la mia famiglia che mi ha sempre voluto
molto bene mi faceva capire che il cibo
in quel momento storico in quel periodo
non aveva la stessa approvazione
culturale non era considerato
un'opportunità culturale non era
considerato una opportunità
professionale chi lavorava nel settore
alimentare
non aveva così tanta riconoscimento
sociale Infatti un altro ricordo è un
pranzo di famiglia Al termine delle
scuole medie mi girai verso la mia
famiglia e dissi io vorrei fare
l'istituto alberghiero e tutti
improvvisamente si girarono e mi dissero
Ma come Francesca tu vuoi dare da
mangiare alle persone per tutta la vita
vuoi non esserci nei giorni di festa
vuoi non riposarti la domenica e quindi
io in quel momento da buona figlia e da
buona nipote Scelsi di continuare il mio
percorso accademico mi iscrissi al liceo
scientifico e successivamente mi
iscrissi a Giurisprudenza ma
costantemente tutti questi passaggi
erano sempre caratterizzati da una
grande sensazione di incompletezza io
parlavo una lingua che gli altri non
capivano era la lingua del cibo era lì
il luogo in cui io realmente mi sentivo
collegata a me stessa ma era molto
difficile quindi nel mio percorso ogni
volta che raggiung Evo un obiettivo
accademico quindi superavo un esame mi
andavo a premiare acquistando un libro
di cucina o partecipando a un workshop a
una fiera cercando in qualsiasi modo di
avere più informazioni possibili di
raccogliere più esperienze possibili
intorno al cibo inteso non solamente
come elemento di nutrimento o elemento
gastronomico della nostra vita ma anche
come elemento sociale dell'importanza
che il cibo aveva nella nostra
società quindi continuo il mio percorso
addirittura nella mia tesi di
laurea ringrazio le mie pentole me lo
ricordo benissimo dicevo ringrazio le
mie pentole perché mi ricordano sempre
chi sono e da dove vengo finita
giurisprudenza ho pensato devo trovare
in qualche modo la strada che mi porti
al cibo che mi porti a lavorare in
questo mondo e così mi scrivo in un a un
master in responsabilità e controllo
della qualità nell industria alimentare
mi trasferisco a Torino e per la prima
volta faccio un lavoro che era collegato
a quello che stavo studiando quindi
divento responsabile qualità inizio a
lavorare in una cucina per la prima
volta Ero felicissima ma era una cucina
che produceva 4.000 pasti al giorno per
le scuole e lavoravo per una grande
multinazionale all'apparenza sembrava
che tutto andasse bene che fossi che
dovessi essere felice degli obiettivi
che avevo raggiunto Però tutti giorni
succedeva una cosa io vivevo a Torino in
una bellissima città italiana avevo una
un lavoro stabile e vivevo in una bella
casa nel centro tornavo a casa ogni
giorno dal mio turno di lavoro mi
affacciavo allaa finestra guardavo quel
bellissimo cortile del palazzo storico e
improvvisamente mi mettevo a piangere
c'era qualcosa dentro di me che non mi
faceva stare bene che mi faceva sentire
che mi mancava qualcosa e così Un giorno
durante le vacanze estive torno a
visitare la mia famiglia e incontro un
personaggio un agricoltore che coltivava
grano che aveva appena attivato un
laboratorio di panificazione e anzi
aveva prima trasformato il grano in
farina con un mulino a pietra e era
interessato a trasformare questa questa
farina in pane e mi disse guardandomi
quasi ridendo Mamma mia Francesca magari
mi venissi a dare una mano tu perché la
mia famiglia è completamente
disinteressata a questo progetto lui
rideva io no in quel momento sono
diventata molto seria Ho sentito
improvvisamente il suono di un treno che
stava passando per me Quello era il
momento in cui io ho sentito dover
saltare perché improvvisamente quella
sensazione di mancanza di incompletezza
di lontananza da me stessa Si stava
dissolvendo e così Sono andato dalla mia
famiglia sono andato dal mio compagno e
gli ho detto io voglio tornare a casa e
ho abbandonato tutto nel giro di una
settimana ho lasciato il lavoro Ho
lasciato la grande città e mi sono
immediatamente trasferita sulle mie
colline lì ho cominciato a fare un
lavoro che non avevo mai fatto e per il
quale non avevo mai studiato Perché per
quanto avessi cucinato per passione
nella mia vita ritenevo che la
panificazione fosse un un lavoro di chi
lo sa sapeva fare sicuramente non mio ma
davanti a me vedevo il grano vedevo il
grano crescere e lo vedevo trasformato
in farina e mi rendevo conto che era
quello quello che volevo che lì si
stavano pian piano unendo tutti i pezzi
e sotto le mie mani succedeva un'altra
cosa quell'impasto si trasformava
magicamente e con estrema facilità in
pane guardavo le mie mani e dicevo Ma
com'è possibile Francesca che accada
questo tu non l'hai mai fatto nella tua
vita e in realtà un'altra volta sono
tornata in quella cucina perché mia
nonna per tenermi a Bata dato che era
una bambina piuttosto
irrequieta tutte le volte che impastava
per fare le piadine o per fare le
tagliatelle mi faceva a fianco a lei una
piccola fontana di acqua e farina e io
impastava e guardavo le sue mani e
cercavo di rubare tutti i movimenti con
i miei occhi per fare la stessa cosa che
faceva lei per trasformare quella farina
e acqua in un impasto e così quando dopo
20 anni mi sono ritrovata a fare
quell'azione le mie mani scorrevano
velocemente pian piano incontro quello
che poi sarà il mio maestro
Ivo una persona che ringrazierò per
tutto il resto della mia vita perché
come un giusto maestro Severo ma molto
umile non mi ha imposto le sue regole mi
ha insegnato questo lavoro lasciandomi
libera di farlo come volevo farlo io
volevo fare un pane che sapesse di grano
volevo fare un pane che collegasse la
terra alla bocca delle persone per
permettere alle persone di avere la
consapevolezza della grandezza dei
luoghi che abitiamo e soprattutto il
rispetto e la tutela di chi questi
luoghi ancora li coltiva e li ama con
tantissima passione in quel momento
infatti anche il cibo stava pian piano
prendendo dignità si cominciava a
parlare di cibo etico di cibo
sostenibile di cibo come azione rivoluz
Iaria che potesse permetterci che
potrebbe permetterci di cambiare le
sorti del nostro futuro e Quindi pian
piano comincia a nascere in me la
consapevolezza che ero evoluta e insieme
alla visione del cibo anch'io ero
cambiata stavo diventando un'altra
persona ma stavo diventando la persona
che volevo diventare quella che volevo
essere
Francesca a questo punto arriva un altro
personaggio che è Mauro Uliassi un
giorno suona il mio telefono e per tre
volte ve lo giuro ho buttato giù il
telefono perché non credevo fosse
possibile che un personaggio un
professionista di quel genere venisse da
me a chiedermi di fare il pane per il
suo ristorante quella è stata la prima
volta che ho capito chiaramente che le
cose erano cambiate che non ero più
Francesca che faceva il pane nel piccolo
laboratorio di campagna guardando le
colline ma ero diventata una
panificatrice
e così nel 2018 decido di aprire il mio
luogo del pane in una zona residenziale
della città senza interesse verso
l'esterno io volevo stare all'interno
produrre un pane agricolo con le fine
degli agricoltori che avevo conosciuti
in campagna e distribuirlo all'esterno
ma per Motivi burocratici la
proprietaria mi disse Francesca devi
aprire un negozio all'interno di questo
laboratorio e così feci e quindi mi
trovai di nuovo a connettermi con un
altro elemento il resto del mondo le
persone perché dovevo spiegare perché il
mio pane non era sempre bello e non era
sempre uguale perché non era sempre
pronto allo stesso modo e così è
cominciata Un'altra relazione quelle con
l'ambiente esterno mi sono resa conto di
quanto per quel piccolo impasto quel
piccolo pezzo di pane aveva svolto
un'azione rivoluzionaria per la mia vita
fino a quel momento e a quel punto ha
fatto un'altra cosa ha cominciato a
farmi conoscere quelle persone che di
cui io leggevo la biografia quelli che
chiamavo colleghi ma per me erano
personaggi inarrivabili persone di cui
cercavo di rubare le ricette la storia e
che cercavo di di di collegare a me in
qualsiasi modo questo è successo un
giorno ho incontrato Davide Pasquale
Matteo che sono dei grandissimi
panificatori Ma sono anche delle Grand
dei grandissimi visionari ci siamo
trovati e ho capito in un istante che
non erano solo dei colleghi ma sembrava
per me che ci fossimo conosciuti da
sempre perché tutti vedevamo gli stessi
valori all'interno del pane oggi queste
persone sono alcune di queste persone
sono addir addirittura mie socie con
loro Stiamo costruendo un ambiente di
lavoro Stiamo costruendo delle aziende
in cui si può non solo creare un impatto
positivo sull'ambiente scegliendo un
determinato tipo di processo un
determinato tipo di selezione delle
materie prime Ma si può anche costruire
un modello di lavoro in cui i giovani
possono sentirsi parte attiva possono
sentirsi soddisfatti possono Svegliarsi
la mattina ed essere contenti del lavoro
che
fanno un anno fa è successa una cosa noi
facciamo parte Abbiamo costruito un
gruppo un'associazione
che si chiama panificatori agricoli
urbani siamo dei pazzi panificatori
rivoluzionari che credono che attraverso
il pane potremmo cambiare veramente le
sorti del nostro futuro
mentre parlavamo in cerchio e siccome
siamo dei grandi sognatori sognavamo
alto quindi stavamo volando veramente
alto sono tornata immediatamente su
quella finestra e un'altra volta sono
esplosa in un pianto di gioia Ho
guardato Pasquale l'ho abbracciato e ho
capito una cosa importante il pane mi
aveva collegato a me stessa Mi aveva
anche però collegato al mondo che volevo
con posto delle persone che avevo da
sempre
[Applauso]
cercato